i ragazzi benvenuti questo io sono tra i
j oggi vi parlo di una cosa un po strana
che vi è successa però ve la devo
raccontare
ero su facebook mi aggiunge una ragazza
proveniente dal bangladesh
io dico bo strano come possibile sono
arrivato anche in bangladesh mi fa un po
strano ok e sono conosciuto ma la pa in
bangladesh on potrà quindi l'ho
accettata un pochettino per capire che
cosa fosse successo no magari glielo
spuntato a caso su facebook ma mandato
l'amicizia così niente raggiungo e basta
e finisce lì questa ragazza mi scrive un
secondo dopo che non c'è stato
l'amicizia e mi scrive ciao chi devo
dire una cosa importantissima ti
riguarda
ok dimmi ho parlato con una persona che
si fingeva te per un bel po di tempo e
poi ho scoperto che si trattava di un
fake di una persona che si fingeva te e
questa è una cosa un po curiosa perché
mi era già successa questa roba qua però
non mi era mai successo all'estero cioè
mi succedeva che delle persone in italia
venissero prese in giro pensando di
parlare con me realtà non ero io ero un
fake però c'è per una persona che ha
preso le mie foto ea dall'altra parte
del mondo e si è finta me così mi sono
fatto dare il link del profilo per
vedere da quanto questa persona fosse
attiva come mio fake
vorrei commentare insieme delle cose che
ho visto perché non hanno veramente un
senso
partiamo questa persona si chiama jack
sito o quindi questa ragazza è stata cat
fissata se avete mai visto che fiji
nella nostra vita con la mia persona ed
è orribile questa cosa in realtà però
voglio farvi vedere come questo tipo si
finge me vi prego jack sido come
copertina io che ho un bicchiere di
frutta incredibile primo post qualcuno
qui per essere più vicino
nessuno io non ho capito niente di
quello che ha scritto pro che ha tentato
di parlare italiano ma che lo sa parlare
quindi in breve come si descrive questo
gex ed alias valigia il curioso amante
di messi dialoga tivo loquace vabbè
andiamo a vedere le foto
la prima le preghiere dei tuoi parenti
sono quella mano invisibile che ti salva
la giornata a questo sono io a londra
questo non sono io
vabbè andiamo avanti comunque ragazzino
avanti perché qua c'è da ridere lo
assicura prima foto l'arrivo
dell'inverno oh che bello l'arrivo
dell'inverno
fantastico l'inverno sta arrivando
guarda johnson un sacco di ragazze
asiatiche li scrivono sotto perché stava
tentando di chattare con un sacco di
ragazze poi arriviamo anche a questo
punto più avanti nel video che un
attimino più serio freezing morning si
trova qui a miami o penso che a miami
questo meteo non ci sta non ci ha mai
stato nella storia penso che il mio
minimo di grani saranno 20 però va bene
un importante mi mangia l'estate ci sono
io dai ragazzi non vi prego con sterni
perché mette queste foto
ma non è finita qui perché bad boys in
jungle i ragazzi cattivi nella giungla
io e io trovi vi prego ma come lo fa al
fake con quante ragazze sta chattando
con queste foto vi prego almeno in
america abbiate un po di buon senso su
ste robe sono annoiato nessuno con cui
chattare meglio dormire adesso gli
risponde una ragazza se sei annoiato
vieni e preghiamo invece di dormire non
capito ma vabbè e arriviamo al momento
troppi con il momento topico
introduciamo la pago inverno inverno è
questa queste sono le mie foto d'inverno
state state scattate d'estate queste
foto pro inverno va bene io con un drone
io a barcellona era estate piena in a
roma con roberto quello non è roberto e
questa non è roma amico mio non è roma
fidati e il commento sotto è vuota nice
place ti prego fammi venire il latte
alle ginocchia un pelo meno però vabbè
in roma con roberto un casino un pacato
e stravolto un casino e non è neanche
inverno quindi ai suoi tutto è sbagliato
tutto tutte però vabbè animava ma almeno
che sia credibile sempre censurando il
nome della ragazza chattando perché poi
ho cercato di capire la situazione
adesso io farò un po ovviamente banner e
questo profilo lei mi ha scritto la
ragazza mi ha raccontato che loro sono i
tuoi fratelli guardiamo i fratelli ci
sono fabio fazio
leonardo de carli theo federico clapis e
luciana littizzetto io non so niente
della mia vita quindi ragazzi qualcuno
che si spaccia ma che va bene la tela
già successo
purtroppo ma fuori dall'italia quindi
all'estero e che chatta con ragazze
americane cedra che ci credono
incredibile cioè sta roba perché io
guardavo catfish che era una roba del
genere è esattamente questo era proprio
questa cosa qua dove gente si fingeva
altre persone per parlare con ragazze
ragazzi e che ci credevano e poi
scoprirono che era un fake catfish
uguale solo che sono io il soggetto
orribile orribile e niente a parte
adesso abbiamo scherzato su sta roba
però per quanto sia un argomento che in
realtà fa ridere perché ne succedono di
ogni di ste cose qua è anche un
argomento molto molto molto delicato
perché comunque sembra scontata come
roba ma parlare con qualcuno su internet
è molto pericoloso se voi non sapete con
chi state parlando
ma non solo non è una cosa rivolta ai
ragazzini e rivolta anche agli questa
ragazza cui aveva 24 anni cioè mia mi ha
scritto cose molto toccanti ci abbia
scritto che che si sta veramente tanto
innamorando che pensava di andare a
trovarlo in florida cose in croce
veramente era innamorata persa e quindi
quando tu ti innamori di una persona
online fi cos'è che non dovresti fare ok
e quindi io vi chiedo a tutti non solo
ai più di quanti più grandi perché b per
questa cosa succede a tutti di fare
attenzione a tutte le persone che con
cui parlate con cui avete un dialogo su
internet che non conoscete xkè è molto
molto molto molto molto importante che
voi sappiate bene con chi state parlando
e non da tema informazioni personali non
mandate mai foto ad altra gente che ve
le chiede perché quello che non
conosciate queste persone veramente di
persona anche di fate attenzione a cosa
andate a chi è veramente un attimo che
si fanno le cagate quindi occhio occhio
occhio anche a me è successo giuro anche
a me è successo un tempo tempo fa mi è
successo che siccome mi ero lasciato da
poco stavo male voglio dire quindi mi
sono legato troppo in fretta ad una
persona non rendendomi neanche conto che
fosse un fake quindi anche a me è
successo purtroppo fortunatamente me ne
sono reso conto in tempo però è stato e
poi una delusione incredibile quando
scoprire una cosa
quindi anche io sono stato che ha
fissato una volta a tutti quanti
occhio non pensate di essere più furbi
perché quando pensate di essere più
furbi e lì che ve la prendete nel ciapet
quindi occhio a tutte le persone con cui
parlate ok questo è tutto
io spero abbiate importato una legge
all'inizio e ho voluto mettere un po
sorridere però comunque è un argomento
molto importante quindi ci tenevo a non
tenere tutto il video sul comico perché
è una cosa che comunque senso dire e
ribadire ogni tanto fate attenzione
perché è molto importante
niente questo è tutto ragazzi io andrò a
vivere in florida che fa freddo
a quanto pare fa freddo però vi sia
piaciuto come se ti e piaciuto sono
momento è un mi piace anche originale
comitato dalle schizzare se non sapersi
iscrivetevi e noi come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]